there's been this enormous increase in
inequality and it has moto multiple
dimensions there there is more money at
the top at the beginning
I mean Minh Reagan when Reagan in 1980
started pushing for the kinds of changes
in economic policy it was a there was
awareness that those policies would lead
to more more inequality the idea was
that you lower tax rates at the top and
you free up the economy and you did
regulate and the hope was the idea was
that it would yes there'll be more
inequality but the size the pie would
increase so much so that everybody even
those in the middle of the bottom would
be better off they would get a bigger
piece even if they got a smaller share
well we've had a third of a century now
of this experiment and we can see the
outcome they were right that it would
increase inequality and the share going
to the top one percent has gone to
numbers between 20 and 25 percent that's
a two-fold increase and the share going
to the top one-tenth of one percent has
increased three to fourfold but
unfortunately this idea of trickle-down
economics that everybody would benefit
is absolutely wrong and what has
actually happened is median income
income in the middle has stagnated
income at the bottom you see even worse
so in the middle income today the median
income of in the United States adjusted
for inflation is lower than it was a
quarter of century ago and at the bottom
the minimum wage has not increased for
45 years
so I think that an economic system that
doesn't increase standards of living for
a majority of exciti sings over a period
of a quarter century and at the bottom
has people worse off than they were
almost 50 years ago is a failed economic
system